we are so fortunate and we're all here
to support each other meghan markle is
marking mother's day by supporting
unhoused mothers and mothers to be
alongside prince harry with their
archwell foundation the couple donated
diapers
cleaning supplies and other essential
items to harvest home
a residential program that serves
homeless pregnant women and their babies
look any woman when they're especially
when they're pregnant you're really
vulnerable the organization revealed the
news on instagram on sunday
thanking archwell and proctor and gamble
they also shared a personal letter from
megan in the caption to their posts
she wrote in part quote as a mom and an
expectant mom
i deeply appreciate the significance of
community support
safe and accessible pregnancy resources
and trusted guidance in a nurturing
setting
adding quote thank you for all you do
for the women and mothers who are turned
away elsewhere and no fault of their own
it's a duck and he's about to eat a
piece of bread
megan and harry are parents to son
archie who recently turned two
and a baby girl who's on the way the
former suit star opened up about her
soon-to-be daughter
and this video message played during
global citizens vax
live concert on saturday my husband and
i are thrilled to soon be welcoming a
daughter
it's a feeling of joy we share with
millions of other families around the
world
when we think of her we think of all the
young women and girls around the globe
who must be given the ability and
support to lead us forward
although megan who served as co-chair
for the event alongside prince harry
did not show in person her friend
chrissy teigen did
and she opened up to et on the red
carpet about what she's looking forward
to doing the most
now that she's friends with the duchess
of sussex our new obsession
bff meghan markle is on the chair
tonight like how rad is this
hollywood royalty and actual royalty
coming together this is a dinner date i
would like to go on with you
i know i i feel like i'm like everyone's
holed up in my and what is it montecito
or santa barbara now
yeah but everyone i feel like our world
has just gotten so small
from through this whole pandemic and
everything seeing like even coming to an
event like this
and seeing people again and seeing the
same crew and the same familiar faces
and you're like my god our world is so
small like i miss you
i genuinely miss you right like i miss
being able to interact with people and
it's it's so funny seeing that but like
our little
yeah it's that's what makes me want to
get out the most is like
we need to see each other again you need
to go up to montecito yeah like i did we
need to go to montecito and chill
in the chicken house i mean let's go
archie's
archie's chicken huh yeah that's what it
is yeah i was like clucking hot
either way i mean like a fresh egg and a
squishy teagan omelette in a robe and
then after you guys are bothered
cleaning products what a dream but
they're so wonderful for
for co-chairing this and this is because
this is like obviously such an
incredibly important event that i'm so
happy to be a part of
let's get this over with
you